[Music]
in sucks for the company news submitted
by barbell blockade human man's death
during sex on a business trip was ruled
as a workplace accident no he was on a
business trip it's on company time
Wow damn but then he was having sex on
video any video was he a sex worker so
he's an engineer okay and he goes by
Javier X so Xavier X cuz it's what the X
Xavier anyway so he was found dead in
his hotel room in France cuz he was in a
business trip Oh France was it a hooker
and so he he was having sex with someone
who was not his wife
oh no he wasn't married was a married
man who already [ __ ] high class or low
class hooker I have no idea we don't
know the woman I think she drugged him
so they're saying that oh it's a but she
made him come so far he had a heart
attack she car D beat him yeah he works
for a rail rail road construction
company it's hard for my tongue say that
railroad construction company railroad
construction company that's pretty hard
that's pretty hard so he so the company
insisted that he was not performing
duties when he had this heart attack
while he was having sex yeah oh he was
performing duties all right blaming the
adulteress sex act that he had with a
complete stranger but the the judge the
judges ruled that the employee on
assignment is quote entitled to their
employers protection for the duration of
their mission whether or not the
accident takes place as part of a
professional activity where is an act of
normal life because in a previous case
in a 2016 lower court ruling they stated
that a sexual encounter is an act of
normal life like taking a shower or
eating a meal so because of that other
case Wow
this one says well having sex is part of
normal life oh [ __ ] so if you like are
peeing and you have a heart attack then
that's the company should have protected
you hell yeah much pal yeah you're
responsible for your health
yeah how are they responsible for your
health if it's not in the workplace
because during a company trip it's on
the company trip I thought though
workman's comp stuff and all that like
that's like for accidents or like
directly related to the job you get
tried in France or was on just a
business trip so they're saying that
this is cordsen in France
oh oh so I don't know he's I feel like I
feel like he's French yeah well this
trip was in France this Court ruling is
taking place in in Paris yeah that's why
I thought it was a French it is the
Parisian railroad only because France is
notorious right now for having
interesting laws that are kind of
questionable I would like to say kind of
goes and defies logic questionable quite
I don't know this is officially back way
that's what they called it and so
they're saying that is entitles the
victim's family to benefits from both
the state and the employer yeah so that
means any partners and children will
receive a monthly benefit of up to
eighty percent of his salary until what
would have been his retirement age and a
share of his pension that's cool the
wife gets the cheating [ __ ] like a
cheating husband is dead and she gets
his time I want to move to France oh you
know what sucks though is that it's like
not the money didn't come from him yeah
it's coming from his company yeah yeah
where I'm like yeah you want a pension
that 100% all of that should go to the
family of the wife damn that is that is
really wild because we got a we won't go
Paul he's so lucky he was on that
business trip girl no the family's alot
yeah emotions if I found out you were
dad I'd be like oh my god I'm devastated
and I found out you died because you had
sex with some hooker in France
well there goes that we saw a high-class
hooker me too
yesterday in France we
watching what's high-class and elope I
just think she was higher class because
of the place we were gorgeous she was
like drop dead like how the [ __ ] are you
alive beautiful
we all saw Crazy Horse oh well they're
performers remember she was not the old
Asian guy and they were just making out
the whole time she was clearly an escort
oh I think they were to it like they're
too far I couldn't see that I'm talking
about the performers I'm like well yeah
they're [ __ ] hot but they're not
process I know they're dancers okay she
was like dainty I've never heard you
talk but nicely about anybody but she
was not [ __ ] drooling I'm like dude
how [ __ ] rich are you to afford her
yeah yeah she's not a $10 ho high-class
yeah she was up there so I was like
maybe it's one of those things yeah and
she's like just a little bit of poison I
don't have to [ __ ] you get you drunk a
heart attack
yep and then she takes the money and is
like angry that you were dead because I
couldn't yell at you yeah
I'd never get that closure of being able
dragging you sure you could yell at the
casket imagine feeling that like for
such a long time never being able to
confront you know what I see you there
you know I got a solution for you you
get a medium to channel this plunger
back into their soul and you beat the
[ __ ] out of them you would have to
because you'd have to get over it
somehow I like to feel like you had
something like I need this medium to
channel Steve I want it to look like
Steve - it would never happen [ __ ]
how do they know that this happened did
she so he died back in February 2013
oh gee so this is just a recent ruling
so I'm not sure how it along asked Court
case okay one of the woman who he was
having sex with I'm assuming the
prostitute was a woman hmm but how do
they that is a big assumption you
definitely don't matter got a gay boy
because she's a phrase don't know a
woman at a bar
so they're citing a 2016 case even
though this incident happened in 2013 no
but you said that they were citing this
ruling based off a 2016 fact checker and
though this incident started in together
because it's 2019 now yeah so all this
time oh that's why the ruling happened
after right really happened after the
initial case that they're citing yeah
arguing with Niki's about this no but
I'm saying that at the instant at the
time of the incident 2013 it might have
been a different ruling because there
was no other case to say like now they
can use previous ruling to like support
the claim I guess no no I understand
that but like it should be retroactive
but it's not yeah like it was like three
years after the incident is the case
that there now siting in 2019 yeah it
should be wrong but I mean we're citing
because they're just saying that the
whole normal life is sex is part of but
that's how they win cases is by citing a
different case that went a certain way
and they're like if this happened here
then now it happens here that's what's
so dangerous about like when new rulings
happen awesome has never happened
Burbage is so important it's so yeah I'm
just glad this arguments on bombing wait
so while you get yours is there any
situation do you guys think where this
would be really bad where you'd be like
anything that happens on the workplace
should not beat cousin because in this
case the family is benefiting from it
yeah no it's I'm glad with that in this
case it's yeah it's good but there are
people who manipulate the system in the
rules can use this case and be and
manipulate it in the future and be like
well technically it was that little bit
of that and they use it like soon oh
we're it would be bad is if he didn't
die and then he got money oh yeah that
is whoa yeah like workman's comp i but
he got like injured somehow or had a
heart attack and then had to be in the
hospital or something like broke his on
then still
ability for future cases they might cite
this once right oh the company being
responsible for your health your
internal health at all whatsoever what
if you [ __ ] the chips so hard that his
dicks too raw officer we can't focus on
work involved that's a personal problem
yeah I mean that's it I feel strongly
about that same way how I feel strongly
that the company should not have a say
in whether or not they cover my
birth-control yeah like what the [ __ ]
mm-hmm health care should be health care
I guess yeah yeah it's just workplace
safety that's it they shouldn't worry
about your internal yeah that's your
they can't control if you [ __ ] drink
or smoke or do crazy they shouldn't be
responsible for I don't think they know
I think if you're gonna be if you're
gonna provide health care insurance you
shouldn't have a say and pick and choose
and like what I get and what I don't be
they should just believe it right right
yeah yeah yeah but what if my company
does not believe in birth control
because we are an abstinence cute yeah
but anyway sorry good company is an
abstinence preaching Church program and
we don't believe in your I don't believe
in having sex yeah but I would still say
if you're gonna cover healthcare you're
covering healthcare you shouldn't have
it's pretty private because then they
will I learned this because of the
office but then you have to like pick
and choose what you can cover because
then it affects the rates they have so I
get it but still don't know some don't
have dental we all do people really not
cover birth control yeah
does he have some some because of their
beliefs yeah it's pretty interesting
oh I don't know that mm-hmm wow that's
like some chick-fil-a run thing yeah but
you chick-fil-a doesn't cover it but
they don't work on Sundays how sick is
that yeah I think we can all agree
that's even that's an even thing right
yeah I got a
a pillow pet you know they're like yeah
animals for little kids
I got a pillow pet that was a unicorn
when I first moved here which is right
when the whole chick-fil-a Fiasco thing
was going on and I named it chick-fil-a
and I was like it's a gay unicorn you
got them is it maybe saw whatever size
they're feeling the burn all oh man
they're [ __ ]
no it's like where it can lay flatly oh
yeah yeah and then you can velcro even
have a new version of that desk you a
soldier
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]